the movie opens in Cairo Egypt showing
public chaos in the street a prologue
states that a team of American
archaeologists has Unearthed a new
pyramid buried deep beneath the desert
the locals hold a belief that the
pyramid is cursed and its disclosure
will result in an unavoidable
catastrophe amid the chaos a documentary
crew arrives to film one of the most
significant archaeological discoveries
in Egyptian history I hope it's better
than those aliens in Mexico upon
arriving at the site a news reporter
sunny under cameraman Fitzy begin
reporting on the Discovery they show the
footage of the pyramid emphasizing its
exceptional nature in contrast to the
traditional four-sided Pyramids of Giza
this particular one stands out with its
three sides Sunny mentions the Dr Miles
Holden and his daughter Nora a pair of
archaeologists have the potential to
rewrite history with their remarkable
Discovery as Sunny goes on explaining
the uniqueness of this architectural
feat She's continually interrupted by
The Barking of dogs afterwards she
invites Dr mil miles Holden questioning
him about the specifics of his search
miles elucidates that there are certain
ancient texts referring to the
geographical areas as potential
locations for the Lost Pyramid of aonan
he speculates that this might be related
to the unusual three-sided architecture
they've discovered following this the
crew approaches Norah who clarifies on
camera that the three-sided pyramid is
not the Pyramid of King aenh hatan she
further states that the structure they
are dealing with is buried below the
surface she explains that it takes
Millennia for sand to build up that high
which means that the pyramid structure
predates the rain of aenh hatan by
Generations when Sunny inquires about
archaeologists resistance to using
satellites Nora reveals that many
scientists are hesitant to embrace
Innovation or to deviate from
traditional methodologies later on Miles
Andora tell Sunny about a satellite
orbiting the Earth and show her the
specific area where the pyramid is
located they have figured out a tunnel
to make their way into the pyramid that
leads directly to its tip just the tip
they prom promise intrigued Sunny asks
more about the satellite and Norah
responds that she was inspired by an
article titled SE TI search for
extraterrestrial intelligence it is the
freaking aliens from Mexico Sunny then
inquires if the aliens are using
pyramids as a means to visit Earth but
Norah laughs it off saying she doesn't
believe in such theories throughout
their conversation miles tries to steer
Sunny away from discussing satellites
suggesting that they focus on
archaeology instead however Sunny argues
that the satellite aspect is significant
as it represents the dawn of a new era
in archaeology this disagreement upsets
miles as he believes that the essence of
pure Archaeology is being lost amidst
technological advancements we should be
using our bare hands for this just like
the slaves that built these things later
in the evening Nora is on a phone call
with her mother she assures her that she
will be safe throughout the mission just
then she spots a remotely operated Rover
vehicle called shorty designed by her
boyfriend and fellow team member Michael
Zahir a robotics engineer it turns out
shorty was originally developed by NASA
for Mars roving enabling them to
navigate challenging terrain it is
equipped with built-in recording
capabilities capturing both Visual and
auditory data once inside the pyramid
shorty will transmit realtime footage to
the command center providing valuable
assistance to the mission the next day
the Egyptian laborers who were tasked
with breaking through the tunnel inform
miles that they have found their way
inside the pyramid hearing this smiles's
team accompanied by sunny and her news
reporting crew to the tunnel upon
removing the final Stone an unexpected
explosion takes place releasing a toxic
gas mixed with fungus that engulfs the
vicinity one of the team members who
inhales this air suffers from a panic
attack causing him to collapse to the
ground but before his condition
deteriorates medical personnel quickly
arrive and rescue him a short while
later miles receives a message from the
ministry of Antiquities instructing the
research team to evacuate the area
within 24 hours it's because of the
Mayhem and why WID scale violence caused
by the protests in Cairo as the locals
are against the foreigners intruding on
their pyramids due to this miles decides
to abandon their mission and to depart
by the following morning however Norah
tries to persuade her father to at least
send shorty to see what's actually going
on in the pyramid after a while of
deliberation miles reluctantly agrees to
send the Rover vehicle inside the
pyramid in the next scene an Egyptian
Corporal shadid comes to check on them
and orders the team to leave as soon as
possible Michael who is the only one
under understanding Arabic assures the
officer that they are in the process of
wrapping up their activities and will
depart soon following this Shorty is
sent inside the pyramid in order to map
the interior Michael controls the Rover
and as soon as it enters inside it
detects minimal traces of toxic fumes
The Walls Within the pyramid display the
symbol of Osiris the Egyptian god of the
afterlife and the first pharaoh all of a
sudden shorty is attacked by a
mysterious figure which startles the
team behind the monitor suspecting that
it might might be the same dog from
earlier Michael continues to drive the
Rover even deeper in an unexpected turn
of events the Rover goes offline and
Michael loses all the external control
with the failure of their mission miles
suggests that they return home but
Michael refuses to leave without his $3
million Rover he tries to convince the
team that they Venture inside the
pyramid to retrieve his expensive
creation also citing that it's loaned by
NASA miles is skeptical about it but the
team eventually convinces him to proceed
with the mission shadid also offers them
2 hours of time to recover their device
after this miles Norah Michael sunny and
Fitzy proceed into the pyramid once
inside Nora takes out her own camera to
document her diary miles consistently
cautions the team against touching
anything because the ancient structures
are very unstable which poses a risk of
collapsing at any time a short while
later Michael finds a broken piece of
his Rover which makes him worried as
they Venture deeper Norah discovers a
hole leading upward and urges the team
to to explore it upon climbing through
they come across various objects and
structures which makes them even more
Curious Norah also finds a metallic
structure stained with dried blood
despite being a warning sign she
nonchalantly takes the sample for
further examination during their descent
The Guiding wire supporting miles
unexpectedly snaps causing the team to
lose their sense of direction stranded
without a clear path they enter a room
where Michael locates his missing Rover
however the room's fragile floor
collapses beneath them causing the team
to to fall into a pit to make the
situation even worse a large piece of
debris falls on Michael crushing his leg
and trapping him the team makes every
effort to free him but to no avail in
the midst of their struggle Sunny finds
a hole so she decides to climb out in
search of an exit and seek help but as
she proceeds to ascend she is
unexpectedly attacked by an emaciated
feline creature that scratches her face
oh freaking cats forcing her to retreat
not long after miles stumbles upon a
door and reads its carving warning them
against entering he then suggests that
they wait until the Army comes looking
for them however Norah disagrees as
Michael doesn't have much time and opts
to search for another way out before
leaving him alone she hands him a torch
and kisses him promising to return but
minutes later the group hears Michael
screams prompting miles and Norah to
rush to his Aid when they arrive at the
location they are shocked to only find
his severed leg pinned under a rock the
blood stains on the ground indicates
that he was dragged into a shaft and
devoured by some kind of bloodthirsty
Predator this tragic event leaves Norah
devastated but her father encourages her
to stay with the team and focus on
finding a way out as they reunite with
sunny and Fitzy miles hides the truth
and tells them that Michael crushed
himself while trying to move the stone
the team then continues through the
tunnel and Nora senses that something is
following them her assumption proves to
be correct is they are soon chased by a
pack of the creatures in a state of
panic they hasten their pace and come
across shadid who is there to rescue
them the soldier manages to shoot down
most of the small creatures but he is
eventually attacked and devoured by a
larger Predator witnessing this miles
quickly makes the group turn off all the
lights and hide quietly in a corner to
avoid being detected surely these things
haven't evolved to see in the dark
during this tense moment Fitzy notices
that Sunny's facial scars are getting
infected and her eyes also don't look
good sometime later the team notices a
carved mural that depicts passages from
The Book of the Dead and its guidance
towards achieving immortality miles
explains that it represents the concept
of final judgment where souls are
weighed by the god of death Anubis
against the massive scale held by m the
goddess of truth if the scale balances
the souls are passed into the Afterlife
subsequently the group enters another
tunnel where Miles unintentionally
activates a mechanism triggering a sand
burial booby trap not the boobies no as
the tunnel starts filling with sand the
group runs as fast as they can to save
themselves in the chaos Sunny falls into
a pit and is impaled on several spikes
the others try to rescue her but she
tragically succumbs to her injuries they
all mourn her loss but they must
continue in search of an escape after
walking cluelessly for a while they come
across another missing part of shorty
Fitzy realizes its antenna can be
repurposed to establish communication
with the outside world he ingeniously
rewires the Rover with his camera and
makes it ready to record miles then
sends a video message explaining that he
along with his daughter and a cameraman
are trapped in the excavation site and
need help additionally he also issues a
warning that the pyramid is infested
with deadly creatures so anyone who
decides to come to the rescue must bring
guns later miles discovers a hidden door
and manages to open it revealing a way
to the burial chamber upon venturing
inside they are confronted by a shocking
sight several remains of the deceased as
the group explores further they find the
corpse of a 19th century Explorer along
with his journal detailing a potential
Escape Route however before they can
fully process the information a clawed
hand suddenly pierces through miles's
chest going full Dr zro tearing his
heart out Nora cries out for her father
but Fitzy pulls her away and they flee
to safety to their bad luck the burial
chamber closes on them trapping them
inside left with no alternative Fitzy
makes a brave decision to confront the
deadly creature rather than live in
constant fear as he slowly returns to
the burial chamber he witnesses that
miles is still alive and tied to a large
scale Fitzy captures this harrowing
scene on his camera as the creature
weighs miles's heart to determine his
worthiness for the afterlife finding it
impure the creature eats the heart
resulting in his ultimate demise
following this Fitzy returns to Norah
and shows her the captured footage in
case she wasn't already pissing herself
enough Norah identifies the creature as
a nubis a hybrid Jackal and human who
consumes the hearts of the impure or
guilty people after Anubis departs Fitzy
goes to retrieve the gun from the
deceased Soldier while Norah takes a
flare from her father's lifeless body
moments later she comes across a written
text in the chamber and deciphers a
historical account the pyramid was
constructed to imprison Anubis who is
seeking to reunite with his father
Osiris in order to access the final gate
to heaven upon looking around the
chamber for a while the duo finds a
shaft with a rope ladder and speculates
that the soldiers must have entered the
pyramid through that path without any
delay Norah begins climbing the rope
with Fitzy following suit suddenly
they're ambushed by Anubis who then
snatches Fitzy away come here determined
to escape Norah continues her Ascent but
Anubis comes after her as well in a
desperate move she ignites the flare and
manages to push the creature away she
uses this opportunity to reach the top
of the Rope despite her extreme
exhaustion she is almost out on the
surface when Anubis reappears and
captures her when Nora regains her
Consciousness she finds herself bound to
a pillar in the burial chamber she also
sees Fitzy desperately pleading for for
help tragically Anubis smashes fit's
face in front of her I thought he liked
Hearts but I guess the CGI budget only
allowed for one despite the overwhelming
Terror Nora acts seenly she uses a blade
hidden in her hand to start cutting
through her bonds once free she uses the
same blade to slit anubis's throat as
the creature trembles in pain a horde of
peril cats show up and launch their
attack on him amidst this distraction
Nora makes her Escape but she passes out
just before clearing the pyramid mid's
exit when she awakens she sees a young
boy holding her camera suffering from
scratches and infection Nora pleads with
the boy for help but before they can do
anything Anubis appears from the dark
and lunges at them as the screen cuts to
Black subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching